Ngày bùng tăng bà tổng thống Iran mà số Pregis Kian Tuy Mau,
Nếu này sẽ kiến quyết bảo vệ chục quyền và tổng vẻ lắng thổ,
đồng thời khẳng định, Nguyên gia Đi Răng sẽ không cho phép bất kí lực lượng nèo sâm phạm mạnh tụp ra.
Pháp biểu đủ ông đưa ra tại cuộc gặp bụt chứng ý tế Mohama Dury Chair,
Chia Phà canh đi ở thủ đô Tây Héranh, theo hàng thông tấn ý rõ nữa,
tổng thống Pregis Kian Nhân Mạnh, Iran luôn khai trọng quan hệ hướng nghỉ với các nước lạng diện.
Tuy nhiên, ông Cánh Bảo, Nếu Mỹ hoặc Israel tìa này nghe của tấn công nhà bị Iran từ lãnh thổ của Cút giả khát,
Tây Răng sẽ có biển pháp đất chả, đồng thời khẳng định điều này không đồng ý về việc
ý ban có cần khăn bị các cú giả đó. Chúnga cảnh cảnh cảnh giả tăng,
lực lượng về bình thích mạo hủy sảo bị ran cho biến.
Đà thế này này nghe của tấn công bằng tư lu ở phở thí vị bay không người lấy.
Nhân vào một cân tư chức tháng của Mỹ tại khuán,
thung ngày bà đang thúc báo một số mạnh với tưu ở đã dưới xuống đạo mua rát,
làm bác người bị thương và gây hư hại buồn tò nhạy.
Ở chung gặp lại,
của đối xor áo cho biết các cuộc không kích nhằm vào sân bà is phà hân.
Đà phá hủy một số mạnh bà chính đấu em bị bốn của Iran,
và tấn công cây thống phòng thổ của nước này.
Nhưng dưới biến mấy nạn cho thấy tình hình ăn đến tài trường đồng,
chưa có giấu hiểu sơ hạn nhật.